hi good morning i'm vash i'm one of the
lead research nurses
a vaccine is the most likely ticket back
to normal life
and at the royal free hospital in london
they've started final stage trials of a
prototype made by the biotech company
novavax
patient 93 is the woman in charge of
buying
covid vaccines for the uk stockpile one
of the 270 000 british people to have
volunteered for trials
it's really important that we check the
long term safety of these vaccines
so i'll be coming back for a year after
the second dose
and for routine visits it matters that
we understand how the vaccines
actually perform over the long term
because we need to be sure
that these are safe thanks for
participating and volunteering
but will it be effective the chief
scientist is optimistic
it's possible that some vaccine could be
available before the end of the year
in small amounts for certain groups but
on monday the prime minister was more
cautious
i don't wish to uh to depress him but we
must be realistic about this there's a
good chance
of a vaccine but it cannot be taken for
granted
even the vaccines chief warned we may
just have to accept the first prototypes
won't stop the virus
a partially effective vaccine is better
than no vaccine at all so
a partially effective vaccine will at
least
help those people for whom it is
effective the uk
has spread its bets with six vaccines in
the stockpile
the current leader is made by oxford
university and astrazeneca
results from final stage phase three
studies are due
any day on whether it protects against
the disease
but a u.s trial is on hold while
authorities investigate a possible
adverse reaction close behind is
biontech and pfizer's vaccine
with key phase 3 results due imminently
johnson johnson's vaccine is also in
phase 3 clinical trials but they've been
paused while a possible adverse reaction
is investigated
novavax has just started phase 3 trials
including one of 10
000 people here in the uk two others are
in early stage trials
other scientists are also cautious
immunity wanes rapidly after covered
infection
if the same happens with a vaccine it
may only protect for a month or two
and for elderly people this is a serious
illness and therefore
if we can give hope to those people and
i think it's important but of course it
can't be false hope
we have to be reassured that those
vaccines do what we
we intend it takes a while for
scientists to work out the achilles heel
of a new virus
and while the prototypes currently in
clinical trials are a sign of good
progress
they may not be enough to bring the
pandemic to an end
thomas more sky news